y les contaré lo que he pasado estos
últimos años y les dijera que soy una
persona muy feliz
podrían pensar que estoy un poquito loca
pues sí hace cuatro años a mi mamá le
detectaron un cáncer terminal mis planes
cambiaron me vine a vivir a querétaro y
llevo cuatro años cuidándola y
acompañándola
el cáncer no le ha dejado descansar y
ella no ha dejado de luchar
quien ha cuidado un enfermo puede saber
lo cansado que es
y lo duro que es ver sufrir a las
personas que quieres
pero mientras cuidaba a mi mamá hace dos
años me dicen que yo tengo cáncer
se me fue la sangre al piso
solo de pensar
solo pensar que iba a ser una causa de
sufrimiento para mi mamá para mi familia
me daba un dolor en el corazón
y ahí empezó una aventura una aventura
que nunca me imaginé lo que iba a hacer
les puedo decir que por mucho ha sido el
año más difícil de mi vida
pero también un año de muchos
aprendizajes y un año en que he recibido
muchísimo amor
desde el primer minuto se me complicó mi
cuerpo rechazo el catéter se me quemó la
piel
y empezaron las perdidas
empecé a perder el pelo es horrible ver
cómo se te cae a puños cómo vas dejando
por donde pasas
tu pelo
empecé a perder mis fuerzas yo que soy
una persona súper activa corro subo bajo
voy vengo de repente no tenía fuerzas ni
para levantarme de la cama
unos meses después después de una
operación muy complicada perdí mis
pechos
es duro ver en el espejo todos los días
y cuando pensé que ya no podía ser peor
que ella el año había tenido suficiente
al día siguiente de mi última
quimioterapia falleció uno de los
pilares en mi vida mi papá
y ese fin de semana empezó la pandemia
si todos sufrimos
todos sufrimos todos pasan los momentos
difíciles
nos enfermamos perdemos algún ser
querido
tenemos problemas familiares laborales
emocionales económicos
ya veces todos juntos
volteen a su alrededor
ellos también sufren
todos sufrimos es una realidad que se
nos impone y nos sobrepasa
porque no podemos controlar y muchas
veces no podemos cambiar
entonces si todos sufrimos estamos
condenados a ser infelices
yo creo que no
el sufrimiento y la felicidad no son
conceptos contradictorios
el placer no es felicidad y el
sufrimiento no es tristeza
y porque lo vivimos así
lo vivimos así porque lo creemos así
wikipedia dice que la felicidad es el
antónimo del sufrimiento
yo no lo he vivido así
y no lo creo así
si todos sufrimos pero también todos
tenemos en el fondo de nuestro corazón
ese deseo de ser feliz
todos somos buscadores de la felicidad
vamos por la vida buscando la fórmula de
la felicidad quitando poniendo cambiando
viendo que tengo que hacer para ser
feliz
esperando que pasen las dificultades
para empezar a ser feliz
y podemos quedarnos esperando
hay que aprender a ser felices hoy
deseados toy skin
que el hombre desgraciado porque no sabe
que es feliz
digámosle a los hombres que seamos que
somos felices que la vida es hermosa que
la vida es bella y que estamos llamados
a vivir
tenemos que resignificar nuestro
concepto de felicidad
para mí qué es la felicidad
qué necesito para ser feliz
necesitamos tampoco
y nos queremos aferrar a lo poquito que
podemos controlar cambiar lo que está en
nuestras manos
y hoy quiero compartirles tres
reflexiones que me han ayudado en este
tiempo
uno se vale llorar
se van a ser vulnerables se van a
necesitar a los demás
cuando vemos a alguien llorar le decimos
no llores quisiéramos deshacernos del
dolor quisiéramos que los que amamos no
sufran
quisiéramos esconderlo en un cajón
se vale llorar es necesario llorar es
necesario necesitar a los demás
necesitamos conectar con nuestra
realidad con nuestro dolor para poder
empezar a vivir para poder empezar a ser
felices
seamos vulnerables no tengamos miedo a
llorar todos lloramos a escondidas en
público por quienes somos más llorones
que otros todos lloramos y se vale
llorar
no estamos llamados a tener una vida
perfecta a tener una familia perfecta un
trabajo perfecto unas calificaciones
perfectas no
estamos llamados a ser felices a vivir
en plenitud ya contagiar la alegría de
vivir
pero se vale llorar y es el primer paso
de la felicidad
aprender a llorar
aceptar nuestra realidad aceptar nuestro
dolor abrazar nuestro dolor
no pasa nada
y hay que pasar por ahí
no hay peor sufrimiento que el que no se
acepta
uno se vale llorar
2 se vale aprender
el sufrimiento es el mejor maestro de la
vida el mejor maestro de la felicidad y
le tenemos tanto miedo
huimos de él quisiéramos que no
estuviera y volteamos para otro lado
pero si queremos aprender a ser felices
tenemos que aprender a sufrir aprender a
vivir cada día como venga no todo en la
vida sufrimiento también hay días
bonitos y también en mi vida ha tenido
muchos momentos de gozo la semana pasada
nació mi sobrina ayer fue mi cumpleaños
he disfrutado mucho y hay que disfrutar
los días bonitos y también los días
difíciles
pero hay que aprender hay que aprender a
vivir
hace unos años buenos años tenemos un
poquito menos escucho una frase que me
cambió la manera de ver la vida y decía
que el arte de aprender a vivir es el
arte de aprender a vivir en el misterio
yo que soy super controladora eso de
vivir en el misterio como que no me
cuadraba mucho pero le dado vueltas en
el corazón y qué implica esto de vivir
en el misterio
implica no tratar de entender
implica no querer controlar
implica trascender
somos tan controladores quisiéramos
tener la vida perfecta saber qué pasó
sigue
pero el arte de aprender a vivir es el
arte de aprender a vivir en el misterio
nadie nos enseña a sufrir en la
universidad no hay una clase de
sufrimiento ni una clase de la felicidad
pero a sufrir se aprende en gerundio
sufriendo ya sonreír sonriendo ya vivir
viviendo
no podemos dejar de aprender
y hay dos cosas necesarias para aprender
bueno que al menos en mi experiencia me
han ayudado
una es escuchar
dice amadeo change in y que la vida
habla si hay un corazón que escucha
hay que escucharnos hay que escuchar las
circunstancias
hay que escuchar a los demás
escuchar para aprender hay cosas que
nosotros no vemos a veces necesitamos
necesitamos que otros nos motiven nos
animen nos hagan ver otra realidad de la
vida escuchar
y lo otro es frenar y se los dice
alguien que es muy acelerada y que le
cuesta eso de frenar a veces tengo que
meter el freno de mano y decir dónde
estoy a dónde voy qué está pasando y
cómo se vive esto
frenar frenar para conectar con nuestro
dolor para conectar con nuestra realidad
para conectar con nuestra vida con
nosotros mismos ir a nuestro interior y
decir como estoy donde estoy a dónde voy
no podemos dejar de aprender
y aprendamos a vivir en el misterio
a no querer controlar a no querer
entender
aprendamos a vivir
uno se vale llorar dos se vale aprender
pero no se vale rajarse
esto me lo repetía muchísimo mi papá no
sabe les rajarse
dice el estudio de la felicidad de
harvard que el 40 por ciento de nuestra
felicidad está en nuestras manos la
actitud fuera un en un lugar muy
importante en nuestra vida
no podemos dejar de luchar la vida es
corta la vida es hermosa estamos
llamados a vivir y a dar vida a
contagiar la alegría de vivir
no podemos dejar de luchar
no se va a leer bajarse
las dificultades pasan las
circunstancias cambian o no pero tenemos
que aprender y se puede ser feliz en
medio del dolor
yo vengo aquí a decirles con mi vida que
sí se puede
que si se puede
no se vale rajarse
no se vale dejar de luchar se vale
llorar pero no se vale dejar de luchar
nosotros necesitamos de los demás y los
demás los necesitan a nosotros
no se vale rajarse
entonces se puede ser feliz en medio del
dolor
yo estoy convencida que sí
y lo digo después de haber llorado de
haber aprendido y de haber luchado mucho
la felicidad está en el corazón no en
las circunstancias
seamos felices y busquemos hacer felices
a los demás
quiero terminar con esta pregunta
y tú estás listo para ser feliz
[Aplausos]